ah ah it tastes like cold barf
I love juicy buffalo wings
I could dip my fries in the sauce it's
delicious I love the flow sauce on
pretty much everything I don't think
there are many people who don't like
buffalo chicken I'm not really a big
Buffalo chicken guy in general Abby I
know probably lot of people would be
ashamed to hear me say that
well chick is just it's just one of the
best things on earth I like milkshakes
they can be a little much vanilla I know
it sounds plain but like vanilla bean
milkshake kind of playing that's really
that's my job I like it so much that
even though I'm lactose intolerant I'll
still drink a milkshake
[Music]
it's a nice color it's not unappetizing
the chicken is actually the one thing is
actually kind of helping it a little bit
because it's the one thing that looks
like a normal piece of food the blue
cheese chunks are kind of gross looking
worst thing I've tried a BuzzFeed the
aftertaste is really it's something the
feeling it's like if someone loogied in
their mouth and spit it down your throat
it comes more tolerable as you uh work
through it's kinda like drinking ketchup
I feel like this could be a good base
for like a Bloody Mary situation cuz
it's already got that like
worchestershire kind of spiciness I
think with some vodka and some more
vodka it would be pretty good it's
inconsistent it's not even the same like
you're drinking it it tastes bad and
then you took another sip and it tastes
bad in a different way it's like if you
freeze people's like sweat after the gym
and then just put in made it into a
popsicle like if somebody offered me
some money not a lot of money like a
decent amount of money I would down like
a couple of these
it has the consistency of like diarrhea
you know like oh oh it didn't taste
enough like buffalo sauce for me I would
have really preferred it to be like
straight buffalo sauce next time I have
a milkshake I'm definitely gonna think
about this a little bit like I'm gonna
have it and I'm gonna be like is this
gonna taste like blue cheese chicken and
milk already sounds bad together but it
didn't even taste bad in the way I
thought it tastes it tastes the worst it
surprised me
excuse me see it's already coming back
up sorry